believe
terrier très bien à los angeles ben
alors oui bénin à ce sujet est-ce que je
peux me permettre de prendre la parole
de petites minutes signature d'
interpeller et je n'ai encore rien
bonsoir eva et merci par avance et va
j'ai besoin de vous on a besoin de vous
tous parce que en fait cyril hanouna que
vous connaissez la est désormais
célibataire
depuis peu or il a vient de le dire un
petit pied-à-terre à los angeles et me
trompe vous avez également un autre
pied-à-terre à new york ce cas là pas de
dévoiler tout
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ce qui veut dire que moi miami a pas
grand chose vous avez rien mieux rien
s'il vous plaît ap des uva dire qu'il a
peut-être 2,3 à tâches qui peuvent sont
susceptibles d'être voit la peau pour
lui là bas aux états unis et comme vous
vous êtes très sympa et que l'on voit
vous aider les gens et que je sens que
le célibat lui pèse est-ce qu'il serait
peut-être possible qu'on passe en revue
les résumer vos amis pour que
éventuellement on voit si ça peut
marcher ou pas vous êtes d'accord j'ai
préparé j'aurai trombinoscope pour aider
cyril parce que tant le besoin
je n'étais je n'étais pas ou non aller
avec mes david beckham non mais non mais
non je ne touche pas dans les chais pas
comme ça vous n'êtes pas jaloux mais pas
du tout dans ce message visiting nom
david beckham puis j'adore à non
franchement donc tu fanon alors non
allergène j'ai une proposition c'est que
vous connaissez peut-être eva mendes
oui avec cyril ça rend chez son frère
joseph and see
alors pour l'entreprise de btp mag la
salle mendès
une de vos amis qui s'appelle kerry
washington
non mais c'est vrai mais bon ce sont des
femmes formidables mais maria maria il
va sortir alors je passe alors je pense
pas qu'elle soit mariée margot robbie si
tu
connais pas c'est qu'elle est sympa et
elle a l'air sympa très bien papa sur
cette photo il
est marié
marié mais bon il ya
est ce que vous pensez par exemple sert
il serait à la hauteur de ben affleck
nous rêvons alors moi m'a pas laissé une
pastèque
[Rires]
maintenant elle est célibataire d'une
paire lopez
sait jamais ce qu'on écrit ce qu'on
n'est pas multi prison ohlala
s'il vous plaît on est avec l'américain
louie asher qui est célibataire
j'ai dit ça
va pas cacher c'est les belges souffrent
également je vais vous et l'apprécié
beaucoup aussi reese whitherspoon à
16 mois les longs
et intelligente non
c'est sûr que non c'est sûr que dans nos
bouchons c'est sauf feeling et basse
c'est ce feeling voilà et non à l'écouté
d'autres pays en ce moment qui bien
qu'ils rentrent divorce c'est kim
kardashian et
j'étais vous savez que c'était ma boîte
de production qui produit son
jeu c'est bien aussi non c'est fini à la
note américaine big mac mais attendez
mais qu'en pense m à est ce que vous
pensez il va que ça pourrait
éventuellement intéressés way he has
va j'ai l'impression que vous foutez de
ma gueule
je le dis comme ça donc je vous aime
beaucoup voilà
qui les occupent kim kim est est ce que
vous pensez vous pouvez vous pourriez
organisé à dont le puy le petit
pied-à-terre de série la new york ou à
los angeles mais obtient un dîner
oui en plus elle est toujours un pari à
la bombe à écouter on va voir en tout
cas il va vous êtes un amour merci nous
occuper de moi
et merci ben haim surtout voilà je me
sens en détresse alors je mets en body
int ou pas du tout loin de là